This is equivalent to the number of queries we make of the black box. Let's see if just one query will
work. Here's the result. We measured cubit 0 to be zero. So that was the
input value x and cubit 1 to be 1, which was the output value f ofx. So now we
know f of0 equals 1. But what about f of 1? Here's where the problem lies. Once
we measured the state, the superp positions collapsed and we only got to measure one part of the function with a
single query. This doesn't tell us everything we need to know to determine which function it is. We would need a
second query of the box for that. So even though the principle of quantum parallelism allows us to simultaneously
have the black box evaluate f of 0 and f of 1, we don't have access to both of
those answers. Quantum parallelism alone is not enough. Deutsche's algorithm
shows how we can use quantum parallelism a little differently to learn about the function inside the black box. We won't
be able to learn exactly what the function is, but we will be able to learn something new about it with a
single query that we couldn't with a classical computer. Let's start by looking at a chart of the four possible
functions taking a single bit to another single bit. Here you can see that two of the functions f_sub_1 and f_sub_4 always
return a single value regardless of the input state. We call these two functions
constant. f_sub_2 and f_sub_3 will return either zero or one depending on
the state of x. We call these two functions balanced. Deutsche's algorithm
determines if the function is constant or balanced by making some clever adjustments to the circuit we used
before. Here's the circuit. It starts by preparing cubit 0 in the state 1 /
2 0 + 1 with a hatamard as before and cubit 1 in the state 1 / 2 0 -1
with a not gate followed by a hatamard.
So the full state at this point here is where this is the state of cubit 0 and
this is the state of cubit 1. Preparing cubit one in such a way rather than just
leaving it in the state zero enables the algorithm to use quantum parallelism in combination with interference to learn
about the blackbox function. Let's see how when the cubits are fed into UF the blackbox gate a couple things can
happen. If the function is constant, then the black box will perform some operation on cubit one alone regardless
of the state of zero. In this case, since UF doesn't touch cubit zero or
care about its state at all, then the second hatomard here just undoes what
the first hatamard did. And we'll measure the cubit to be in the state zero. Let's look at the balanced function f_sub_2 as an example to see
what uf does to the state in this case. When x is zero, f ofx is zero and when x
is 1, f ofx is 1. Remember what I told you about the ufgate. It takes cubit 0
as our input x state and outputs f ofx on cubit 1. Assuming that cubit 1
started in the zero state. So for this function what UF does to cubit 1 depends
on cubit 0. If 0 is zero then cubit 1 will be left in the zero state to get f
ofx= 0. If cubit 0 is 1 the black box will apply a not gate to cubit 1 and put
it in the state one. So we get f of 1 equals 1. This is exactly what a controlled knot or a c knot gate does. A
C knot gate takes two cubits, a control cubit and a target cubit, and flips the
state of the target cubit if the control cubit is in the state one. But it does nothing to the target if the control
cubit is in the state zero. So UF for F2 is just a C knot on Q0 and Q1. The C
knot gate will do nothing to the first term since the control cubit is in the state zero. But on the second term, this
zero flips to one and this one flips to zero. And if we factor out a minus sign, we'll see that the state of cubit 1 is
unchanged. But this term has picked up a minus sign. So the state of cubit 0 is
actually the one that has changed. It went from being 0 + 1 to being 0 minus
one. When we apply the final hatomard to cubit 0, this transforms it to the state 1. So if the function in the black box
is f_sub_2, we'll measure a one instead of a zero. It turns out that the UF gate for the other balance function f3 is the
same C knot gate followed by a knot on cubit 1. That final not gate doesn't affect cubit zero. So when the function
is balanced, we'll measure cubit 0 to be in the one state at the end of the circuit. Now if you didn't follow all of
this, that's all right. I suggest you go through it on your own to see how it works. The major point here is what
happened when we applied the C knot for the two balanced functions. Cubit 0 was only used as a control cubit to change
the state of cubit 1. Intuitively, you might think that cubit 0 would remain unchanged. And yet, somehow our
operations on cubit one actually change the state of cubit zero by changing the relative phase between the two parts of
its superp position. This phenomenon is known as the phase kickback mechanism and it's
super counterintuitive like a lot of quantum phenomena. In a way, you can think of the phase kickback mechanism
like rowing a boat. The act of pushing water backwards actually propels you forward. Just like the operations on
cubit 1 actually change cubit zero. Now we can run Deutsche's algorithm on
Qiskit. Here we can select which function to put inside the black box which we've chosen to be F3. Here's the
circuit diagram of the algorithm and we can run it as before with the sampler primitive. We'll set the number of
samples to just one and see what we measure. In this case, we measured one.
So, we know that the function was balanced, which is indeed what we expected since the black box contained the function f3. So, with just a single
query, we were able to differentiate between these two classes of functions.
This would have taken a classical algorithm two queries to determine. This shows a modest advantage of quantum
computing over classical computing alone, but it's not too impressive. Just one versus two. But Deutsche's algorithm